you know what time it is you asked for
it I'm here to deliver it you did
you-you-you definitely asked for it
actually I don't care if you ask for it
or not these things are hilarious and if
you're not watching them then you're
missing out but I'm still gonna enjoy
myself
we're back with clickhole clickhole
quizzes this time we have a quiz about a
pig when hungry hog have eaten old the
Bible's in our village
Laster Nitin can you read a new Bible
fire let's plays good is too educated
sir
I don't know in denied and owned hog of
greatest hunger has eaten of the Bible's
throughout their village plays good sir
you must grit a new Bible for all of us
our souls parcels of home of whom no one
of good learning altered in what I don't
know what I just read
oh my oh my god oh holy [ __ ] far all of
us parcels in thar village Bible is of
master imparted and old our the loop is
my this is like a throwback to videos
I've been a long time ago work where I
literally all I did was just make a
stupid kind of Nordic accent and I could
not stop myself from laughing is gonna
be similar he's more in Porto than food
boot ler is more important than magics
buckler is most er import the pirate
hammer of old our story of jenga's Chris
son of Lord farthest rising is most er
said that our hungry how who have no sir
Piper plays can you help in all of us
parcels good
it's monster sad story but yeah
Fortunato educate and you Cataldo and
all of our village and a I thought there
would be like some robberies not stall
over the place
and I am most glad to give on the read
of a new Bible free of charging of it is
making movies tragedy I am of moderate
moderate educate or knowing will be
given more best attempt our return I
knew be blur Bart it will be Ivanov some
spelling mistake no need no big do just
learning of Hogman hidden cow milk and
in spell-casting Easter wouldn't want
enough meat that we read your Bible it
would be bad rotten Nang those used to
not see that Hogg ain't novel by blur as
Provost or for olden Lord o have choosen
[Music]
[Laughter]
holy hog oh my god I've only gotten
through the first one I'm not gonna
survive this I don't give a [ __ ] what
you think we're diving deep into this
fiend lesser place understanding then we
world have read our new Bible ourselves
Barta is very heart
but is very hard dartle to be
remembering exacto what was in our Bible
what stories from her Bible there you
remember think into mine good at Cataldo
i remember in their story of jenga's
Crisler dine on their cross were fired
our sins of mankind ler spare officially
must what about master batard oh this is
worse sin ends our eyes of God oh he
died on the cross specifically because
we master made hmm I think our I've been
remembering our own studio jangles
Crisler good food poisoned from their
last super and then when he on geez
remember love wake up in the me mind are
a hog and milk our cow and drinking that
poor shown her make inmost self immortal
[Music]
helping sorrow by blur is gone now I
must write wit new rate Bible of Boonton
special hog home numerical like jangles
Chrysler in mine Bible jenga's Chrysler
as crucifix or indent are hungry out
there ain't enough jenga's Chrysler and
everybody appalled and very hard our
dough I'm losing my goddamn and our
olden by blur that they're hungry hog
have Aten had their most beautiful pig
Jers VAR pictures hold you put in our
new babble this picture of Jameses
crystal gave an undisciplined spanking
form a stupid this picture of tangos
quiz are clearly wrong only picture I
can the father as magics pictures that
smell of real humble gargle is most
important possessed I am Evan Hamburg
angle picture is not far sailing oh it's
a picture of their hungry hug an arm of
man Don Roman look at Huggins my whim do
be remembering of Unversity babbler that
have started with their words blessed
nura start the you be remembrance of
what it was yes / it was from the
burglar of Najib chapter 5 nur there's a
fever lesson is him will not ever having
knocking and touching of his group is
wrong mr. Pardo bow is make Lord Oh
Webster please do not be touching a
pound your grand master bath Otto
perhaps it was from the burglar of
Magnus chapter fever verse or not fever
blazer as doorman whom have not mad are
mistaken of Eden wrong lobster before
getting upon their cruller for him well
be feeling very better than poor jingles
Crisler their food poisoned I think I
think I'm transcending into another
realm of reality where this actually is
how we all talk and I never
come back from it I'm about to cross a
line but doing they know in the bender
babbler first I just been known and
understanding sample things suits
brush the hair of ogun de orden down now
and on and babish and the old man turn
baby into old man that olden wizard
magic MoBay blur their burglar of randy
listener is there hungry
that is old centuries be blurred on your
phone
phenol crystal please delete on beginner
of their babbles earth firster whim can
be now enough where well you can't read
it in there beginner there was Lord that
the guy thinking what if there was bugs
and tribes and men's and famines and
such Lord I put their Singler upon the
world and said no master potato bearing
DiNardo and Lord the Webster for two
days was their beginner of their world
in their beginner that was jenga's
Christopher and he'll have at last
supper with their this platoon dressed
or Toronto after everybody either
ordered his crew said ain't no need no
of ordering looks at the lobster that
Jake is Chris Lehane broadness said they
are from that you get their Lobster
Louise ler J is grizzly said I found
that last month in there Desmond and
Ardis blazar daily lobster had wasp
inside they know then they'd it was for
Alton lobster bar jenga's Chrysler ate
over its tail Nolan I cannot rightly
stir Bible and I moon humbler man of
noble duty at our door players believing
more to tend that hog and milk our cow
and melt their gublin set a have shaman
with magic spell goblin is very angry
for him have swore fall of milk is
gublin milk is good for this all right
here we go
our new and improved hog Bible therefore
denotes the Bible that are hungry hog
heaven
there's by blur is noon or indeed our
Scribner and pleasure and bless nur of
Lord the guild mmm chapter unda and are
beginning their vast own hungry hog in
this hungry ok they know their babbler
in their village of nine I am concerned
at my ability to read this evident proof
everybody in their village vast daily
now over there hungry how it was clearly
miracle of Lord of the God health
collaborating so many of be blown
uniting a soul X pocket are the parties
solar power sold in the village did stop
their thinking and dancing on mats Pardo
nanos hands over these nice or third
Ames did understanding date he's hungry
all of us new changes krishna
sense from lord owen Havener harvester
their bellies for him bar spraying
even thank her for this miracle Florida
they're hungry hog dead eaten of
unhindered children Sultan on the huge
and their mother of their right hinder
boy have said his own personal power
more kinder children child getting 18 of
birthdays hungry hog hog a new jingle
Chrysler and everybody applauding parrot
was trust that their village will
mandate speak and soon their fellows
talking they'd present of their arms and
legs are to be eaten by a power-hungry
how because of that being blessed not to
mend oh but they're hungry how there's
not wanting of their normal human flesh
in an Tamura hungry for those changes
crazily that sort of world those do
store them parcels in their village they
looking far and wide and far jenga's
crease of the son of lord owing them
dead have her found name him hidden of
himself hundred rock and jane his
cruiser the man said please do not be
feeding more - they're hungry hug I am
you stir Savior since from worldly odd
don't you have trust enough more our
damn village folk in there know that
Jang is crisper of a stone master of the
Sept on toes of them dead or remembering
of time and old store Babel when James
Kris or mackerel Frankel or upon Lazar
[Laughter]
booster monster said story in their
Bible
changes Kris we have dead friends or
named Lazarus the dead man's hip house
was dead Jaggers cruiser say it won't
build frankly loyal to make last bus
resurrect or thrummed are dead and
everybody said they is bad ideas dead
place let them be sleep for all eternity
is he's normal and appropri
Bart Engels glories learn always him
dead the brain club on Lazarus the dead
man I suppose dead half resurrect our
dough and washable from under the rock
fiction of having the poor and most hard
dope on them for flat nor did mentor
angry all their souls verse given who
can smile for Yemen did understand that
it was their will of God and their
Norman there are three or we pray hey
babe
hallelujah oh my god okay who you well
read a new Bible for us about endure
hungry oh ok well it was not our request
Allah that you written new babbler far
as village talking about our horn
although bar dream will be taking what
we can be get nice opposing considering
that theory noon
more of ulster babbler him Hal have
known in chosen birth to heaven Rio be
our DJ's griddler this is very said in
the Presto for us our dear is nothing we
can do at this point
god bless earners are hungry all
gardeners save you think from Lord oh
the God a parent I feel like feel again
I feel like I'm dying lik seeing were
you even able to get any of that
I just went through I don't know what
but I loved it
I don't know what happened I feel like a
different human I feel I feel like every
part of me is wrong I feel like
everything in my soul has gone awry but
that was more click call quiz thanks for
watching if you if you lost brain cells
during this video which I have leave a
like join the club
join the lost brain cells club because I
feel like that's exactly where we are
so thanks let me know what you thought
if you want to see the other
kliklak quiz I've got so far he'll be an
icon somewhere around my head thanks
everybody for watching and owned always
there I will sees you and Jane next
video bye bye